Russia and Syria as we mentioned say to
Israeli fighter jets carried out a
deadly airstrike on a Syrian base so far
Israel is not saying anything about it
of course panic Connor Powell has the
latest from Jerusalem tonight it is an
airstrike no government has claimed
responsibility for but Moscow is
pointing the finger squarely at Israel
for the early morning bombing of a
Syrian Air Base near Homs which killed
at least 14 people including Iranian
soldiers - Sykes must be investigated of
course this is a very dangerous
development officially Israel is not
involved in the war in Syria but since
2011 Israeli policy has been to prevent
any transfers of advanced weapons to
groups like Hezbollah and so to protect
this redline Israel has launched dozens
of airstrikes in Syria
like previous attacks in Syria Israeli
leaders have refused to officially
comment the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu issued this warning today
neutral mclubbe we have one clear and
simple rule and we seek to express it
constantly if someone tries to attack
you raise up and attack him but with the
buildup of Iranian forces in Syria
particularly Iran's air force Israel
appears to be setting a new red line for
its Syrian policy in February Israeli
Jets struck the t4 airfield after an
Iranian launch drone crossed into
Israeli territory one Israeli jet was
shot down during the mission and
recently Prime Minister Netanyahu has
pressed President Trump to do more to
confront Iran in Syria fearing an
Iranian buildup of forces near the
Israeli border regardless of how the
Trump administration decides to react to
the growing Iranian presence in Syria
one thing is clear the Israeli
government will continue to attack any
group it sees as a threat Bret Connor
Palin our Middle East news room in
Jerusalem Connor thanks